over 100 billion searches a month 1.1
billion Android devices activated 500
million Gmail users just some of the
numbers behind Google's staggering
success in its first decade as a public
company Google has grown from 3,000 to
52,000 employees annual revenue of 3
billion dollars to 47 billion plus and a
market cap 17 times its IPO valuation on
the way Google has become a fixture in
popular culture the name a twist on a
math term has turned from a noun to a
verb used around the world whether at
home or on the moon Google products help
users find where they're going see what
their house looks like from space what
streets and mountains look like a world
away but the core remains searched the
company commands more than 67 percent
share in the US and Google is still not
satisfied what I think about search it's
such a deep thing for all of us you know
to really understand what you want
understand the world's information we're
still very much in the early stages of
that search has helped Google become an
advertising juggernaut and with all that
cash Google has branched out big time it
bought YouTube and grew it into the
world's largest video site Android is
the world's dominant smartphone platform
they're more than 1.1 billion users of
Android and we activate something like a
million
that number is growing very dramatically
but there have been challenges
allegations of user tracking scanning
emails manipulating page rankings I
think the main thing that we need to do
is show them what data's being collected
which is getting people more choice and
more awareness yet for Google awareness
means thinking about the future reaching
for the stars with its Google X lab
Google X is about doing brand new risky
technological things that are sort of
you know the making science fiction real
these so called moon shots include
Google glass the self-driving car robots
even trying to prolong life itself and
identify what the ideal healthy human
being would look like so what grew from
a garage to the world's largest search
engine has now become a company
searching for breakthroughs people have
only dreamed of